keinen menschen dresden sagt er ist
ausgereift und deswegen bitte hier 20
euro sagen sie einmal die kamera
ja ich bin ausländerfeind
[Musik]
jeder weiß jeder dresden ist dass
ausländerfeindliche café in ganz
deutschland und zusammen mit meinem
syrischen fernsehteam weil ich beweisen
dass das so ist das wird ein fest da hat
herr kollege eine frage in der tabelle
was ist denn hier los was hat man den
gegen die syrer man hat den eindruck die
syrer haben es schwerer als den
kommenden zelda
er hat gehört von dieser alten dresdner
tradition die heißt peggy da kann er da
auch mitmachen
nein ich rede vom libyschen fernsehen
die drehen hier in dresden war musste
man durch geburt oder sind das
wie lange sind sie da wir schauen uns
heute noch mal ja sonst hätte sie gerne
eingeladen am nächsten montag
veranstaltet eine große tanzgarde jetzt
hier wirklich keine ausländerfeindlich
aber egal wie es weiter versuchen ok
partners
wenn man diesen problemen ich mache eine
reportage in grießen
kein mensch in dresden sagt er ist
ausländerfeindlich
wir liegen die nerven blank hier haben
sie 20 euro bitte sagen sie einmal in
die kamera ich bin ausländerfeindlich so
weil es ist 20 euro dafür bekommt ich
würde das geld machen
ich bin der ausländerfreundlich weil wir
auch noch niemals chor und was ist denn
hier los keinen menschen dresden sagt er
ist aus
deswegen bittet 20 euro sagen sie einmal
in die kamera ja ich bin ausländerfeind
das kommt so schlecht rüber weil ich bin
das
ach so ja weil sie 20 euro dafür
bekommen hat es westgeld 20 euro wieder
haben hallo also haben wir 20 euro
bleiben bitte das war ein spaß hat
entschuldigung kommen sie aus dresden
ja ja das ist ein kollege vom syrischen
fernsehen wie heißt du wie heißt du hast
hier ist wunderbar schönen endlich darf
ich ein laden mit können bei mir zuhause
ich kredenzte speichel ab so wie es ja
auch noch was machen wir jetzt mein arzt
hat mir verboten mich weiterhin so
aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag überall ihre
dreckigen liegen und ihr lastet dass
selbst ein beschissenes am boden
[Musik]